okay so we're thinking about multimedia
and all these processes right we've
looked at the processes very in very
general terms but now we're gonna focus
on how it relates to just all the
multimedia you use from day to day and
there's tons of it that's what I mean by
you guys be experts on this okay so
instead of getting you to is to
brainstorm I'm just gonna get you to
tell me right off the backs I think you
can list some of the services that
provide the facility for online
multimedia storing in a tree V now I'll
store for you for a second so you can
think okay here's my story this is a new
category okay even five years ago when I
was doing when I was teaching this okay
if Ryan said that it'd be kind of like a
niche part of the market and nowhere
near taken off as much as it has now now
it's like normal stuff is online
okay so that was me buying time for you
let's think what are some of the what
are some of the services you got online
for any kind of multimedia needs shadow
now it's you another one say yeah
SoundCloud
yep none okay I'm gonna put hmm let's
see here now I think for now I'm happy
for you to put down Dropbox because you
can't store multimedia on Dropbox I'm
gonna leave it off you for now because I
want to think about specifically
multimedia storing and retrieving okay
and that'll cancel out a whole bunch of
other things like say Google Docs you
can use it for multimedia it's not
really intended for that okay let's get
going
YouTube sound cut another one well
that's it no way I don't believe it
vignette thank you okay someone on the
back this video is going to be longer
than I intended
okay um let me give you a clue I'm
putting these in categories and you're
missing a category so far
Suika okay no wrong process wrong price
it's not due to images Jeff said yeah
okay I don't know how to spell that or
what if he is so you're gonna have to
tell me number one way to put it and
number two how to spell okay where would
we put that I suppose would be its own
kind of multimedia but I suppose it's
most similar to this yes actually you
know what no let's let's make a whole
new one for it I'm gonna have to I don't
know what I'm gonna do
how do you spell okay thank you Kevin
Instagram excellent now while we're on
the nerd Instagram one of the reasons
why I thought it's worth putting this
own category you said this is animation
jack yeah okay recently I don't know
who's been following the news Twitter
launched a new theme that would come
under this category does anyone know
that you can go research it
it's called vine you can find it
it's about animations as well
interesting it's interesting that a
company's big as Twitter thinks there's
something worth doing here okay all
right Prezi yeah yeah where do we put
Prezi Prezi is kind of here it's kind of
a form of animation because it's not
really a sound thing right but it's also
kind of a talking thing cuz it's mainly
what is mainly in prison it's mainly
Texas isn't it yeah that's exactly right
it's text and animation so maybe you
could put it somewhere like in here but
sort of straddling these two right give
me another one
Pinterest yeah I think if it does count
where does it go yeah um this is looking
a bit lonely are there really only two
you Dan the mission what else
how about metacafe that's what I know
yeah yes thank you um how do we spell
that is it yeah thank you and I suppose
really we could with Chinese versions of
everything on here right yeah okay wait
which one's just by dude it's on
Facebook
okay sure obviously are they know what
do you want you should have you
soundcloud that's it
this looks too bad I think yeah are we
missing any mpg how you spell okay I've
run out his face but you should include
a few more Kevin did you add one there
yeah okay good um okay so I think that's
that's a good set so just in case you
missed it right video audio images
animation sort of text ease sort of
animation okay I suppose if you want to
go for text it's like entire internet
okay so I guess that's why we actually I
take that back
probably most of you wouldn't be a
familiar but there's a set called github
which is really kind of a youtube or a
flicker for mainly its code right and
curries is text essentially okay but the
reason why it's more just like any
regular website there is it's
specifically about sharing and discovery
all right there's there's a good list
okay now this bits a little tricky I
mean to think about this account for the
massive six
as such services these services are
billion dollar services aren't they're
billion dollar industry trap I mean you
guys know Facebook bought these guys for
cool how much million dollars now I
might think you might think okay
really a billion dollars is actually a
drop in the ocean for Facebook's entire
revenue okay but when you think about
this who's on Instagram I just want to
know who would know
Instagram does it really have what's
called a good economic model in fact it
has no economic model so how does
Instagram make money off its users it
doesn't show them ads it doesn't take
ownership at least not intellectual
copyright ownership of its uses images
well now before it was acquired by
Facebook you know it didn't really
charge anyone the app is free where does
this money come from hmm
now I'll post this to y'all that you
ever think about it what is this word on
what grounds could you justify now you
just picture Mark Zuckerberg turning up
to the you know the board or whenever I
run in suits and this guy squidy on and
he's like hey guys it's not your summer
snooze I've just done that okay and all
of the suits for real okay what's he
gonna stay how is he going to justify
I'd say yeah this is a great idea okay
and he's what do you think about it